بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله اما بعد كرياض
الصالحين
الحافظ النووي
يقول وعن ابي زيد اسامه بن زيد زيد بن
حارثه مولى رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
وحبه وابن حبه رضي الله عنهما
ابي زيد اسامه بن زيد بن حارثه
رضي الله عنه الله
قال ارسلت بنت النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ان ابني قد احتضر فاشهدنا
صلى الله عليه وسلم
someone
tell him
was taking breath so please come and be
here while he passes away
this child was a very small child an
infant unable to speak and the
صلى الله عليه وسلم
فارسل يقرئ السلام ويقول ان لله ما اخذ
وله ما اعطى وكل شيء عنده باجل مسمى
فلتصبر ولتحتسب
الله
[Silence]
ارسلت اليه تقسم عليه لينها
صلى الله عليه وسلم
himself
person why is that well there's a number
of reasons ‏But most chief and most
importantly
is when someone passes away
a small child these are the things that
are most important to be heard and most
important things to be believed and h in
one's heart and as for
a person being there or not being there
this is not going to
‏sit also
the prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
you know this is this is aent and if to
come he would not be able to change this
child's destiny would not be able to
withhold this child soul from leaving
his body this is something الله سبحانه
وتالى
صلى الله عليه وسلم
this time الله
[Silence]
insisting would come
قال فقام ومعه سعد بن عباده
اسامه بنزيد
number
the most major of the companions this
gives us this gives us a bit of an
insight into the kinds of people that
around him also from the names
‏some
of some gather
because peopleent
alles
propbes
whenes
would callbes
‏and
people these companions whose names are
here many of them of the propet scribbes
and all of them people of knowledge so
they having some kind of some kind of
having to do with the quر or what have
you
and
فقام ومعه سعد بن عباده اسامه بن زيد
سعد بن عباده سعد بن عباده
الانصار
‏and
the ban
on the day of
the conquest of me he was the one that
was given the ban and leadership of that
part of the army during the conquest of
jaذal
weve discussed so many times here
حلال حرام
صلى الله عليه وسلم يمن ابوذر
وابي بن كعب
قران
وزيد بن ثابت
ابو بكر عمر
زيد بنثبت
عثمان عفان
مصاحفire
ورجال رضي
اسمه
فرفع الى رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
الصبي
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
فاقعده في حجره ونفسه تقعقع
ففاضت عيناه
صلى الله عليه
عليه الصلاه والسلام فقال سعد سعد بن
عباده يا رسول الله ما هذا
الله
سعد رضي الله
‏was
is this contr to paent
and so this could be underst that if
trent i would c be happy no this doesn't
mean a person will be happy but a person
will contr himself and so the حافظ صلى
الله عليه وسلم هذه رحمه جعلها الله تعالى
في قلوب عباده
وفي روايه في قلوب من شاء من عباده
mer الله
وانما يرحم من وانما يرحم الله من عباده
الرحماء
الله
بخاري
مسلم نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه
وجوده ان يثبت قلوبنا وافئدتنا نساله
تعالى ان يغفر لنا خطايانا وان
يتوب علينا والله اعلم وصلى صل الله وسلم
على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
والحمد لله رب العالمين